foreign
hey everybody what's going on it's
Tuesday and we're doing a movie review
the greasy Strangler yeah this shit's
ridiculous
I can't remember which one of you guys
recommended it I think like more than
one person did and so I finally like put
it in the poll and it won like
overwhelmingly yeah if you like Napoleon
Dynamite which I like that movie you'd
like this I liked it I liked the movie
it's like Napoleon Dynamite meets John
Waters like early John Waters meets Tim
and Eric it's kind of like that like if
you like that kind of thing then you'll
probably like this kind of thing but
this is definitely a what the [__] that
I just watched kind of movie Over the
Top ridiculous
it's supposed to be I can't decide if I
I don't know like while we were watching
it last night I said at one point I said
I think this is either legitimately the
funniest or like the most horrible movie
I've ever seen it's the same time
it's basically like this movie is the
world's largest collection of bucket
absolutely losers just in one play and
they all think they're cool as [__] you
know what I mean there's nothing cool
about them they're just [__] fun that
tries to be so uncool and it comes back
around and becomes cool again just like
in when Napoleon Dynamite you know yeah
it's so it's really very advised very
much like Napoleon except much grocer
yeah real disgusting it's like real
gross and like and it's sexual and [__]
yeah and it's like meant to be gross
like but like I said that's where I was
getting like the Earth like early John
Waters you know I'm like eating dog [__]
era like John Waters like that kind of
stuff it's like that but they're trying
to shock you yeah which and I don't know
if it was necessarily shocking I mean I
wasn't like you know you just laughing
right that's what I mean it's like you
know in in 2016 when this movie came out
I don't think anybody would necessarily
be shocked by it unless they hadn't seen
movies before ever but um but you could
tell that it was like trying really you
know what I didn't realize this is a
British director really Jim hosking okay
um yeah this is his first feature length
film uh he had actually done some shorts
and he did if you've seen the horror
Anthology ABCs of death 2 which came out
in 2014 he did the segment that was
called G is for granddad but um but yeah
so he's very interested in
grotesquery I guess and just like making
things as gross like I said it's you can
tell he's trying to do like a John
Waters type of thing but you know John
Waters when he was doing that like back
in the 70s or whatever yeah it was like
really shocking back then because nobody
had done that but I kind of feel like
nowadays it's not a shocking but it does
stand out though it does stand out
though and this I this was still like
um really entertaining and surprisingly
well shot yeah it was good the
cinematography was actually really nice
which I thought was like not nice but
like just well thought out you know what
I mean
this had to been a low budget movie uh
but it's it seems like it was but it's
good quality and uh it was punching
above its weight you know kind of like
the way philosophaster is but it does
but it's just it's different the
writing's good it's [__] bizarre all
right yeah it's very easy pudding but
it's meant to be often like it's
deliberately off-putting they're just
this poor cast man
I was you know what the whole time we
were watching it all I could think of
was like I wonder what the casting call
looked like like the ads that they ran
yeah like what like the types of people
that they were looking for or it could
be that I don't know because the the
director was British but like all the
actors were I'm presuming American they
all sound American so it's just kind of
I mean that doesn't mean anything but
you know what I mean well one guy was
one guy was Indian another guy was
asking again yeah that's true and uh the
other guy was from some other country I
forgot what it was they and some of them
it can't either they can't act or
they're acting like they can't act I
think that was that was a deliberate
Choice yeah because like I said it was
meant to be that's another thing too is
the the tone of it much like Napoleon
Dynamite it's just like overtly awkward
yeah like it's just trying to make you
as uncomfortable as possible like
they'll do like these segments where you
will get into it in a second but they'll
do these segments where it's just like
one joke and they'll just like repeat it
like over and over and over and over and
it just goes on and on and on and then
like At first it's like it gets annoying
and then it gets funny and then it gets
kind of annoying and stupid again and
then it kind of gets funny again you
know what I mean it's just kind of like
this whole cycle that they're doing so
they're trying to make [__] that's very
uncool they're trying to make it cool
[Laughter]
using
trying to be cool
that's cool yeah they're just very
deliberately trying to yeah well it's
almost kind of like this is not really
even set I don't know where they shot
this
um I was reading a review of it
somewhere that said it looked like Los
Angeles yeah it might have been Los
Angeles but I was thinking about it
early and you will think about this
movie after you see it like however you
feel about it
um you're not gonna be able to like ever
scrub it out of your brain I guarantee
that whether you liked it or not but I
was thinking about it later and I was
just kind of like I how
unpopulated the movie is yeah like so
many of the shots are just like the just
like the characters like just the two of
them there's like nobody else around and
so it almost has like a little bit of a
surreal well it's kind of It kind of
comes across like slightly surreal yeah
I feel like just because there's like no
one around and just because everyone is
like acting and talking the way like
normal people don't talk yeah it's
really artificial but it's supposed to
be yeah that's what I mean
it's like a bunch of [__] what do you
call them artists everybody is like
autistic in this or something it's just
there's just something else man they're
pitiful but that they're supposed to be
but yeah it's deliberately imagine if
Napoleon Dynamite was about a serial
killer that's what this is
it was like a hundred times grosser yeah
and they had
they got everything that like from
serial killer type tropes you know in
this in this case it's like a father and
son team and there's weird like sexual
stuff going on between there having sex
with the same woman and he's leaving
it's just it's weird and the woman is
it's kind of kind of like something off
a [__] what was the name of those two
dudes the dudes the uh the confession
machine
yeah even though those dudes I think
only killed a couple people they lied
said they killed a whole bunch of them
but
the relationships in their lives are
kind of like this or at least the lives
they claim to have had had you know just
bottom of the barrel you know I saw this
actually really insightful discussion of
this movie
um I can't remember what the name of the
channel was but they were talking about
and this may be a weird thing to say but
as
you know uh as deliberately appalling as
this movie is as deliberately offensive
as is it's trying to be it actually is a
pretty nuanced examination I know what
you're saying you're starting to roll
your eyes already of a codependent
family relationship like the the
relationship between the Son and the
father is [__] up and really really
unhealthy and it kind of goes into that
some
um and the more you think about it like
I was watching I think it was off the
shelf reviews who were like two British
guys and they usually do horror movies
and they did they talked about this
movie for like half an hour and the one
of them like really dug it and he said
even if you didn't like it the first
time he's like watch it again because
like a lot more will come out the second
time and he said that the second time he
watched it he found it even funnier than
the first time
so maybe I think the first time you
watch it you're just sitting there going
what the [__] is this like what am I
watching well I saw Napoleon Dynamite
twice and it was better the second time
the first time I saw it I was so
disoriented I wasn't quite sure what I
was seeing it took maybe that's why
maybe that's what he meant because you
know we've only seen it once and I've
seen other movies like this so I wasn't
quite as what you know what I mean like
I was a little bit like what okay but
you know uh but it's just kind of like
so maybe I'm kind of interested maybe I
will watch it again like someday but I
mean it is pretty gross they show
they're showing it for free yeah it's on
Amazon Prime yeah which if you have
Amazon Prime it's free yeah it's well
worth a watch if you like horror movies
and you like it's not a horror movie
though it is no it kind of it's both
it's it's a it's like if if Napoleon
Dynamite was a horror movie about a
serial killer yeah like that it's kind
of like more a black comedy but it does
have horror elements to it like the
greasy Strangler himself
um you know he does kill people there is
kind of like Gore but it it's just like
over the top go like he'll strangle them
so hard that their eyeballs pop out and
that's gross [__] man and then like
there's a lot of farting dude old dudes
booty and everything and just there's a
lot of farting and there's a lot of this
dude old people nudity yeah and ugly
people knew
I earned a right to be nude
sometimes I hate to tell you we gotta
earn right to be nude on camera I guess
but uh because man this will hurt your
eyes man it'll really hurt your eyes
and the girl that they're loving on
she's the least ugly out of this but
she's her face isn't ugly she's just got
a terrible build you know she and she's
just looking
she's a great she does a great
performance she can act you know she's
really the only one that is has been in
like some other stuff you know what I
mean
Elizabeth durazo her name is yeah she's
[__] funny she's in like some other
uh comedy I can't remember like a comedy
series but I can't that woman is her her
her body is a box it's just a rectangle
with legs yeah pretty much yeah and
they show you a lot of it and sex scenes
and [__] and these yeah I mean like 90
of the movie is people walking around
naked or almost completely naked yeah
and uh having orgies and [__] in the
house and while the sun could hear and
just it's weird you know it is amusing
but it does kind of it the the subtext
is very disturbing it's supposed to be
now she says it's not a horror movie I
say it is but it's a horror movie in the
uh in in the uh in the way that the tone
of the actual horror type scenes kind of
reminded me of of uh early Carpenter
kind about like you think maybe yeah
there's some kind of carpenter-esque
about it like I said I got a very very
John Waters vibe from this I don't know
any of those movies you don't know you
haven't you've never seen Amazon water
pink flamingos or cry baby I've never
seen a Serial Mom never seen it you've
never seen it a hairspray no I've never
seen it you never saw hairspray no we
watched the remake of hairspray but John
Waters did the original one
the one with the I'm I'm sure we've
watched that movie
I can't believe you've never seen a John
Waters movie that's [__] crazy no
yeah John Waters is a [__] genius man
he's from Baltimore but yeah that was
his whole thing like him and uh
particularly the movies that he made in
the 70s
um you know wasn't it Pink Flamingos
where uh where Devine was wanting to be
like the filthiest person alive like I
don't know what kind of before my time I
mean when that when those movies came
out I think I was in the eighth grade I
wasn't interested well I saw him later
yeah I didn't see that later just
because I don't think I ever saw that at
the VHS rental place they probably would
have had that like in the gay section or
something no it was it would have been
in comedy would it okay yeah their
comedies but they're like grotesque
comedies okay I never even noticed him I
never even noticed those movies anywhere
near the sections we would go to to go
rent movies yeah they'd have been in
comedy and like their comedies but like
I said they're they're disgusting but
they're it much like this one is it's
you know meant to be disgusting it's
meant to like push boundaries you know
what I mean
um now one I think I was watching um one
review of this of Mark carmod who he
didn't really like it he thought he
actually thought it was just boring but
um he said that
I think it was him that said it he said
you could tell that this is somebody
that's like trying to be like a John
Waters movie but the John Waters had um
grotesque weird characters but you could
tell that he loved those characters and
in this one you're not really sure how
the director feels about these
characters I haven't I can't comment
because I've never seen anything yeah I
mean I get that I get where you could
say that because this one I kind of feel
like it's a lot more yeah John Waters
his movies are like gross but they come
across like a lot more Charming because
you can tell that he has a lot of
affection for these weirdos that he's
that he's filming but this one
I mean it's kind of the same Vibe but I
think that he's kind of like not I get
like a more sense of like Detachment
like the director may be like detached
and not in the sense that he loves these
people or he wants you to sympathize
with these people he's just showing you
these people and he's and he's showing
you like the most disgusting things I
think he thinks these people are
ridiculous yeah that's what I mean so
that's so that's kind of the difference
this that's why it's not exactly like a
John Waters movie but it's kind of in
that ballpark though so like if you
liked John Waters early movies you might
like this too but that might be
something that you want to consider
because that's I think that's kind of
the difference like as soon as somebody
said that like I don't remember if it
was Mark Carmen but it was because I
watched a bunch of different reviews of
this but I think that's the difference
yeah that'd be the difference between
Napoleon Dynamite in Napoleon Dynamite
those weird ass characters you could
tell the director loves those characters
they're the heroes okay yeah they're
they're good people yeah these guys are
they're the opposite
that's the thing like the the main okay
or pitiful people
I will argue that even the ones that got
killed were were kind of annoying yeah
you know what I mean yeah everyone in
this is kind of like there's somebody
you wouldn't want to hang out with yeah
now I will say that like the Sun
character
um what's his name big Brayden big
Brayden everybody's big something big
somebody
um big Brayden who's the main character
he's sympathetic to a degree like he's a
nice person you know what I mean uh his
dad Big Ronnie is horrible
um the girl is initially uh she's
initially likable but then it seems like
she's kind of like shitty too and like
and stuff and then the other people were
kind of like well I don't know like big
Paul the guy that owned the car wash
where the greasy Strangler would go he's
okay he was he seemed like a nice man
but he was blind he couldn't see what
was going on literally yeah
was a well actually guy well actually
remember he got killed you know and uh
the African guy was I think too trusting
everybody had some kind of fatal flaw in
him in the way the way that they were
and they were all Annoying what about
oinker I forgot which one that was the
one with the pig nose
uh his whole problem is that he couldn't
choose France
he just thought everybody was his friend
poorly yeah him and his little new shoes
that he got
but yeah so if in case we're kind of
like talking around what happens in this
movie like I said I don't think it's
spoiler alert or nothing like that
because they tell you who the greasy
Strangler is in the trailer as far as I
know yeah and they're not they don't
make any secret over the movie it's not
like a whodunit or nothing like that
um you basically know that big Ronnie is
the greasy Strangler like from pretty
much the beginning of the movie
so uh so yeah so you have big Brayden
who's the son and Big Ronnie who's the
dad and they're two disgusting dudes and
they live in a disgusting house and Big
Ronnie his big thing is Greece I mean he
loves eating grease like yeah yeah like
pretty much like any yeah so his whole
thing is like big Brayden has still is
living in the house with him
and he has to cook for him but it's like
the food that he cooks is like never
greasy enough like he's bacon it's like
he's just like pouring grease on it he's
like I wonder why people don't put
grease in their coffee and like all this
other stuff so there's a lot of like
eating really really greasy like goopy
food there's a lot of that going on too
which actually kind of makes me want to
hurl but yeah so there's a lot of that
and he's talking about grease like it's
an elevated thing and it's beautiful
because it's greasy
[Laughter]
you know just he'll just go out about
how [__] beautiful Greece is yeah but
it's it's crazy it's just everything big
Braden is like what am I what are the
lines that made me laugh for some reason
he was like um he's like you know Greece
is bad for you I read it in our in a
fitness magazine that I found on the bus
or something like that because they're
both kind of like really
he's kind of old and like out of shape
and stuff and like I said everybody is
just like yeah skinny fat just funny
just like old and baggy and and nasty
and they're just like walking around
either in little bitty underwear or
naked all the time and um Big Ronnie the
dad he has
um a person I guess that's a prosthetic
penis
so he's just like walking around naked
all the time so what so what Big Ronnie
and Big Brayden do for a job is they do
a walking tour that's about locations
having to do with Disco
um even though I'm pretty sure they just
made all of them up so like they take
they take people around the city and
they'll be like and in this doorway like
a member of the Bee Gees like once had
their picture taken or something like
that and they both wear this ridiculous
outfit that's like a pink turtleneck
right yeah it was shorts and then it's
like shorts that are also kind of pink I
just they're not like sparkly but
they're kind of like a pink pattern type
of thing and so they both wear that and
so they take they just take these groups
of people around like tell them about
all these disco things so the thing
about Big Ronnie is that he has all of
these stories about you know back in the
day when him and John Travolta were
gonna open a disco together and he hung
out with Michael Jackson and like all
this other stuff and he's just full of
crap he's just like making stuff up but
that's kind of another thing too is that
they just call each other [__]
artists all the time and that's another
scene because remember how I said
earlier like how there's all these
scenes that just go on forever and ever
and ever and ever there's one scene
where they're having an argument and
they're that's their biggest
um like epithet that they throw at each
other as [__] artists and they just
say and they say that like instead of
[__] sometimes like where you
somebody would say something stupid
you'd be like [__] they'd be like
[__] artist and so they just keep
doing and they just keep calling each
other that and it goes on for so long it
goes on just like forever and you're
like oh my God how [__] long can they
make this kind of [__] go on it's just
that whole cringe because I know that
there's like a whole sub-genre I knew
people that did that kind of that of
yeah like the kids of that cringe comedy
and it's it's kind of like that where
you just like how [__] long can this
bit go on like there was that and like
there was the whole thing too at the
near the beginning where the Indian guy
and the other two guys were like trying
to get the chips out of the vending
machine at the hotel and like they
wouldn't come out and then he the the
Indian guy was like trying to tell him
what like what was in the chips and he
couldn't pronounce potato right and
remember like the other guy kept saying
he's like I'm sorry what Porto yeah yeah
and it's like and they did that like and
it went on for it seemed like an
eternity that that [__] [__] went on
and I mean I think it was just like a
minute or two but it seemed like an
eternity because they just kept
repeating again and it just kept
repeating it and it it's like after a
while they keep repeating it so much
that you just like can't help but laugh
because it's like what else you're gonna
do because you can't believe that
they're just like continuing with it and
there's a lot of scenes like that a lot
of scenes like that where it's just kind
of so I don't know so I'm just telling
you that because it's like if that's
gonna get on your nerves then there's a
lot of that well it's supposed to get on
your nerves yeah that's what I mean it's
very very and you know and the
background score too is deliberately
made to be as annoying as possible
um so if that's if you don't want to
watch something that's just trying to
annoy you and gross you out on purpose
then this is not the movie for you but
I don't know I did find it like very
entertaining it is gross
um I didn't find it all that shocking
necessarily and I did actually find it
pretty funny
but
humor is really subjective I just I
don't know I saw like a wide gamut of
reviews like some people
um really vibed with it and just thought
it was hilarious and then some people
just thought it was the stupidest most
irritating thing ever and they hated it
and they hated every five you know every
minute of it
um it was supposed to be like that
though yeah yeah yeah you're supposed to
not like what's going on yeah I
understand it I understand the movie I
liked the movie
um I'd watch it again
I probably would too get a rest and go
back and watch it again like after a
while yeah there's yeah it's all right
like I said it would probably be funnier
the second time because I'm sure you'd
pick up on a lot more stuff because it's
not just the interesting thing about it
and the more I thought about it the more
I was you know this was occurring to me
is that it's not just gross or shocking
for the sake of being that like it is to
an extent but it seems like he thought
about it more like it's actually like I
said it's really it's very well shot
it's it's kind of like well thought out
or like well put together like it's
paced kind of weird and I can see how
like like I said because Mark car mode
just he's like well I get what they were
trying to do but I just thought it was
really boring
um I could see that too because the
pacing is kind of strange and I mean
it's not long I think it's only 90
minutes
but
I don't know there is just something
really really interesting about it it's
almost like and they he was deliberately
you could tell he was deliberately
trying to make a cult film as well which
doesn't usually work you really have to
be careful about
setting out to make a cult movie because
usually that just blows up in your face
because it's too try hard and I feel
like this movie just barely it's just
kind of on the line of like maybe being
a little bit too try hard I didn't find
it
to try hard but one iota in either
direction it probably could have been
you know what I mean I don't know and
like I said everybody's line for that is
going to be different
because I do kind of feel like if you're
like oh I'm definitely gonna make a
[__] cult classic I mean whether he
was trying to I mean he definitely was
trying to but it did work because I
didn't see this movie this movie came
out a while back it came out back in
2016. and I I remember hearing a lot of
people talking about it like it got a
lot of buzz but for some reason I just
like never got around to watching it and
then I just kind of forgot about it
until one of you guys recommended it and
then I was like oh okay yeah I have I
remember hearing about that and hearing
that was a big thing and then when I
went back and like started researching
it I was like um yeah this is like
pretty it's not
massive but it has like a big cult
following and then I'm sitting there
going because when I was watching the
movie I'm like I wonder if this has a
big enough cult following to have like
Halloween costumes like based on it
because some of the outfits in it are
like pretty ridiculous and would make
some really good costumes and yep as
soon as I Googled it like looking for a
poster I was like I saw a couple that
had dressed up like in the pink disco
outfits I didn't see anybody dressing up
if you've seen the movie you know what
I'm talking about but big Ronnie's disco
dancing outfit which is essentially like
a a deep v-necked purple velvet
pant suit
with a with a um it's like crotchless
it's like was it like mesh I don't
remember but like the whole like the
whole area that the whole area of like
the crotch was like
see-through
the the thing that big Ronnie were to go
to the to go to the Disco the purple
thing where he just did the one dance
move over and over and again yeah where
he just kept like I don't remember what
he was wearing really I can't believe
you forgot that it was like a yeah it's
like a purple [__] pantsuit with this
dick sticking out yeah I wouldn't be
looking for that you know what I mean
you couldn't I'm a man you couldn't
that's it I didn't even remember what he
was wearing [__] stupid dance he was
doing you couldn't miss it now that
scene made me laugh a lot well his
outfit made me laugh a lot I was like
that would make well because of when I
was watching that it didn't look any
different than the other [__] that he
was wearing though well no but I didn't
mean was like that it occurred to me
that it's like that would be a funny
Halloween costume nobody would get the
reference well no because I did see what
like I said that I was just saying when
you weren't in here was that um I
actually when I was doing research for
this show uh there's a lot of people
that dress up as Halloween costumes
because this actually has like a very
very large cult following so
um so yeah now if you wore the thing
that he wore to the Disco you probably
would have to just wear that to an adult
party because
European would be showing even if it
wasn't a real one but you know it would
still be pretty funny like probably only
five people would get it but it would
still be funny I would think laughs
uh Jam Spector said uh I got to see that
movie at a party a few wait a few years
back it's very quotable yeah it
definitely is there's a lot of
there's a lot of like bits and lines in
this that yeah if you if you saw it with
friends and I would recommend
watching this with a group of people
preferably drinking and or high
um would probably really enhance the
experience I feel like like seeing in a
theater would probably be good
um or seeing it at a party would
probably be good because this really
needs group Synergy I feel like like
watching it by yourself I don't think
it's going to be as fun
GM Specter also says the music was
annoying and great at the same time yeah
it was just that's kind of like the
whole vibe of the movie I felt like it
was kind of like deliberately
provocative and annoying but it was also
like pretty funny and like pretty
entertaining yeah that's why I don't
know why people are mad no one's mad
well you said a lot of people rejected
the movie that it was no I said some
people some people hated it or most
people like most people that hated it
didn't hate it because they thought it
was offensive they hated it because they
thought it was boring oh okay I don't
think it was boring it's not a boring
movie
I mean just the concept alone I feel
like is enough to but but like I said
humor is subjective so like your sense
of humor is gonna go a long way toward
whether you're gonna like this movie or
not mango says uh marker mode used to be
a good film reviewer sadly not anymore
if he recommends a movie don't bother
with it yeah I mean I usually only watch
I do like him but I haven't seen a lot
of his newer reviews because usually I
just see you know ones of movies that
we're all I'll watch like his couple
minutes like talking about it
but yeah he he seemed to know well the
cool thing about him is that he's seen
everything so it's like he always has
like a good
um like framework for what to talk about
so like when he was talking about this
movie he had like a lot of other things
that he could compare it to and he's
like you know he could tell he was
trying to do this and that and the other
thing
um but mostly he was just like you know
in this day and age like this kind of
thing isn't really that shocking anymore
like depending if you've seen like lots
of movies
um and he just thought it was boring but
uh I don't know but I don't necessarily
agree I can see
like I said the pacing of it is a little
bit weird but
I don't know I kind of feel like the
whole thing was deliberately made to be
as awkward as possible I think the most
entertaining part of it was the greasy
Strangler Parts where Big Ronnie like
basically covers himself in Greece I
guess he has like a you don't find that
salad to the end but he has like a big
barrel of it like in the closet of
Grease like oil and he dips his whole
body in there
and then he runs around strangling
people just because yeah he looks like a
monster what he's gonna be covered yeah
and he basically just he's like growls
like yeah he's like yeah and then when
his mission's over he walks through the
car wash
like he's brand new I did like the
editing that they did because I think
they used the same shot every time like
he would go and and kill somebody like
be it all covered with grease and then
he would go stand in the car wash and
like have the things hit him and I think
they use the same shot every time but
it's like it was funny like every single
time yeah it's just ritual yeah like he
would go and do that and like I said it
was owned the car wash was owned by his
friend big Paul but big Paul was blind
keep big Paul was also into disco
because he was also wearing like 70s
clothes and stuff yeah but he was blind
so he didn't know he thought that big
Ronnie was taking his car through the
car wash she didn't know that he was
just standing in there yeah to like wash
all the grease off well he walked
through it it was one of the kind of
yeah
all the little spinning [__] towelets
and in the
sprays and [__] he walks through it just
like his face was funny and then they
oops sorry not your glasses off and then
they would show him like when naked with
his like freaking Wang like swinging it
away like with the thing like blowing on
it
and he had like that super super white
hair I don't know where that guy that
actor's name is Michael St Michaels
um I don't know what his deal is I don't
know where the director found this guy I
don't know
um this guy is either I kind of feel
like he's like a really really good
actor you know what I mean I bought it
like I bought into the role so that
should say something I don't know if
this guy is really like this
I kind of got that impression because he
was just I don't know it's hard to
explain it's hard to explain this movie
if you haven't seen it it's pretty it's
uh yeah
it's pretty weird
um yeah Mega said uh they're talking
about marker mode yeah yeah
ah and mega said uh I can only say about
95 to 98 of his reviewers the last eight
years he said his first horror film he
saw in the cinema was Texas Chainsaw
Massacre holy [__] that was a long time
ago 1974. and his favorite movie is The
Exorcist yeah I really really do like um
his reviews and usually I agree with him
not always but
um I usually do
but yeah so if you have uh Amazon Prime
because Tom appears to have stopped
talking about well there's no more I can
say about it
there's so much you can say about this
movie though although well honestly like
I said there's the the parts like the
the Strangler parts are good like where
he pops out the people's eyes and eats
them and that kind of stuff I actually
liked the fir maybe one of the first
kills where he punches that guy's face
in and then just the face like goes in
it like caves in like I thought that was
really and actually the special effects
are actually pretty decent that's what I
was gonna say I thought I thought it was
kind of like a carpenter at that at that
level yeah I don't know how much this
cost to make but I mean like I said it
looked like a lot of the a lot of the
cinematography a lot of the shot
compositions were like really really
good we're like really interesting and a
lot of the special effects we're getting
like all the eyeballs popping out and
but like I said if you're gonna be
offended by saggy old people nudity and
pretty graphic
um sex scenes of people with like maybe
bodies you'd rather not look at
um a lot of farting a lot of talking
about poop I kept being afraid that they
were gonna like show more poop stuff and
I'm kind of glad they did it because
just kind of like them talking about it
sort of grossed me out but yeah there's
a lot there's definitely a lot of
farting there's a lot of Grease there's
a lot of just general unpleasantness
um and like I said it's very overtly
sexual there's just kind of well doesn't
big um big Brayden doesn't he have a
micro penis I guess I think he has a
micro penis well because there's one
scene where he's having phone sex with
his girlfriend and just the way that
he's manipulating his hand makes it seem
like he has a micro penis and then I
think they showed at the end but I don't
really remember if they showed it like
oh to any great degree but I think they
showed that he had like a micro penis
because you know yeah Senor stick says
hi all came in at poop
[Laughter]
yeah there's a lot of like I said
there's not
um but like I said they make a lot of
poop references in this movie like
they're just kind of like oh he shits
the bed all the time oh he's [__] on top
of the TV like but then how we got a
bunch of poop references in the review
no I'm just saying that it's like so I
kept being afraid it was that it was
gonna go there but it's like the humor
of the movie she's making it sound like
that that's that the whole movie's that
um really the humor isn't like that it's
just that was only in a couple scenes
it's just that it's kind of like they go
in that direction you're like what the
[__] it's just
it was it was it's a decent movie it's
if you like you you know I just I can
only I I don't want to repeat myself
over and over again if you liked if you
liked uh Napoleon Dynamite you like
horror movies you'd like this one yeah
I'm just gonna say yeah if you like
Napoleon Dynamite mix with early John
Waters then this would probably that's
this is the ballpark that it's in uh
Senor stick says is this a human
centipede situation no not really
um I saw One reviewer that kind of
compared it slightly to Human Centipede
three but I haven't seen that one so I'm
not real sure
so there might be some but like I said I
got more of a John Waters Vibe and or
Napoleon Dynamite kind of thing it's
it's more like that but with a with a
serial killer aspect so there's kind of
like I don't know if I'd call it Gore
but there's kind of like some kills and
they're sort of like over the top a
little bit you know what I mean but not
like super super gory I don't know it's
hard to explain
uh mango said it is a curious movie The
greasy Strangler not for everyone but it
does have some good moments yeah I have
a hard time recommending it because I
don't know
I don't know this seems like when people
are either gonna really love it and Vibe
with it or they're really not gonna get
it
you know what I mean they're just really
really not gonna like it and be like
what the [__] am I watching
so you know it yeah and you know more
than me like what kind of person you are
so you know what I mean so like I said I
can't remember uh who it was that
recommended it but I'm kind of glad I
watched it though it was an interesting
movie and I'm glad that like people are
making weird [__] movies like this in
this day and age even though this one's
like a few years old
but yeah all right
um then watch oh wait a minute
uh well they're talking about X oh I
reviewed that if you're talking to me
but like Tom hasn't watched it you'd
probably like it but I haven't watched
Pearl yet though I gotta get around to
that I've had I've heard mixed reviews
about that some people said it was like
the best movie of last year or whatever
but I'll get around to it I promise all
right so I guess we're gonna wrap it up
uh you know so yeah if you have Amazon
Prime go watch this and uh tell us what
you feel about it because I'm kind of
interested to see what everyone's
comments are gonna be uh so tomorrow is
the main show and we're gonna do another
paranormal show that was what won in the
patreon poll oh yeah what are we doing
ghosts of flight 191 all right which was
a plane crash that happened back in the
70s and apparently there's all kind of
Haunting [__] going on about that
somebody recommended it a long time ago
and I've been putting it in the poll but
this is the first time that it won so
that should be a fun show I guess
um yeah so all right so we'll see you
guys again tomorrow night thanks for
dropping by good night